[Music]
the industrial revolution was a pivotal
period in human history it transformed
our entire world as it reshaped social
and political structures in ways we
hadn't seen since the invention of
agriculture
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream
in this episode of perspectives three
experts discuss how the industrial
revolution shook the modern world in
ways both good and bad
we begin now with a look at events in
europe that set the stage for worldwide
industrialization
[Music]
so in the hundred or so years before the
industrial revolution population was on
the rise increasing demand for food and
many other goods
in some regions farms were producing
more than ever before even with fewer
farmers
this released many rural workers to
participate in the putting out system
that streamlined the production of a
variety of goods
these changes were in addition to the
200-year expansion of european
commercial dominance overseas
the age of discovery was followed by the
creation of neo-europes as european
colonists began migrating overseas at
the end of the 17th century
each of these factors was most prevalent
in great britain and the low countries
but one more factor in setting the
conditions for industrialization remains
to be
discussed
while we could not yet refer to european
countries as nations during the late
17th and early 18th centuries
in the sense of the modern nation state
the state nevertheless had a role to
play in setting the conditions that
would allow for industrialization
it seems intuitive to think that
favorable state policies would spur
growth while unfavorable ones would slow
it
that is of course a modern way to think
about the role of the state
by the early 18th century all states
espoused to one degree or another
mercantilist commercial and economic
policies that employed protectionist
measures to keep imports low
and minimize foreign competition
if and when states downplayed these
mercantilist policies this had less to
do with governments adopting new
economic theories than it did with the
ability of rulers to fulfill their
people's material needs
consequently these policies were not
exactly conducive to free and open trade
at the same time
if there were any one organizing trend
in the political structures of european
states during the 17th and 18th
centuries it was the drive toward the
creation of absolutist monarchies
the movement toward absolutism was
motivated by ever increasing costs of
government and the thirst for new
revenue sources to support it that is
the immediate and rising fiscal
requirements of the centralized
bureaucracy
and the biggest discretionary expense
for governments than as today was the
cost of maintaining armies in navies
probably one of the greatest mechanisms
for british financial stability was the
creation of the bank of england in 1694.
the bank of england allowed the
government to raise secured loans
thereby enhancing the financial security
of the state in ways that many other
states could not until the 19th century
the bank of england was independent of
the monarchy it was a creation of
parliament not the king
divorced from the whims of the crown the
bank offered investors a sense of
security and stability that was
unmatched in other parts of europe
what is the creation of a state bank to
do with industrialization
well financial security and stability it
offered allowed great britain to solve
many of the problems of revenue that
plagued the emerging absolutist states
it allowed for the creation of the
world's largest and most powerful navy
so commerce could rely on the power of
the government to protect trade
the british government never played any
direct or indirect role for that matter
in the development of new industrial
sectors during the 18th century
but the state was able to enjoy
financial stability that proved to be
very advantageous for growth
the general trends that i've just
presented were not restricted to great
britain all over europe greater
agricultural specialization and
increases in agricultural production
were becoming commonplace
labor relations were also shifting as
serfdom declined and labor tended to
become more specialized and centralized
in cities
governments grew in size and tended
toward greater centralization which
spurred new institutions favorable to
commerce
but the unique circumstances that
existed in great britain by about the
middle of the 18th century
made the industrial revolution possible
all that remained was what we might call
the spark of capitalism that would give
rise to industrial production
by 1750 all the preconditions for
modernity were in place but the world
was still in a very traditional state
some spark was needed to push humans
across the next threshold of complexity
into the age of modernity
that spark both literal and metaphorical
was the burning of a substance laid down
by geological processes millions of
years ago a substance called coal
it was lit on a small and hitherto
relatively obscure island off the
northwestern edge of eurasia
britain had depended on wood for most of
its energy before industrialization but
by the 18th century it had begun to run
out of wood
so britain's turned to coal for heating
and cooking sinking mines deeper and
deeper until groundwater seeped in and
flooded the shafts
this was the context in which steam
engines were invented to more
efficiently pump water out of the mines
early in the 1700s thomas newcomen
designed a steam engine with a piston
pushed by steam but it was so
inefficient that it proved almost
useless
it was scottish inventor james watt who
built a much more efficient steam engine
it pumped larger quantities of water and
could also be applied to drive other
types of machinery
in the early 1800s watts steam engine
was attached to spinning and weaving
machines which made rapid cheap mass
production of textiles possible driving
down the price of cotton cloth by 80
by the middle of the 19th century
textiles had become the largest business
in britain employing half a million
people out of 12 million total
they had also destroyed the
comparatively inefficient cotton
industry in india with cheap
british exports the first sign of the
huge shift in global power that was
about to occur
it wasn't long before the iron and steel
industry was similarly transformed
using a technique pioneered by abraham
derby which involved smelting iron by
burning coke instead of charcoal british
iron production sword
later henry bessemer built a blast
furnace to produce an even stronger
version of iron steel although we
shouldn't forget that the chinese han
dynasty had managed something similar 2
000 years earlier
these developments in the coal-fired
steam engine and iron production led to
a dramatic expansion in railway and
maritime transportation
by the mid-19th century almost 13 000
miles of rail tracks had been laid
across britain and steam ships were
crossing the atlantic ocean this was a
veritable explosion of innovation a
revolution driven by collective learning
that allowed humans to soar past the
dying off point thomas malthus had
predicted
the british population and standard of
living reached unprecedented levels and
london became the largest city on earth
london hosted the first world's fair in
1851 showing off the fruits of british
innovation in a vast hall dubbed the
crystal palace itself a marvel of
structural engineering made of iron and
glass covering 19 acres
this damp little island had led the
world into the modern era but more than
that britain had established a model for
industrialization that could be imitated
by other nations in which similar
preconditions existed and in the second
wave belgium france prussia and the
united states all joined the club
before the industrial revolution
britain produced just two percent of the
world's industrial goods
by the middle of the 19th century that
percentage increased tenfold to a
staggering
20 percent
one-fifth of the world's industrial
output
still
the inequities that industrialization
could also produce
are best seen in the cotton industry
the growth in the production of cotton
together with the falling price of
textiles
allowed ordinary people in
industrialized nations to have access to
more textile goods than ever before
but
it also led to an acceleration of the
slave trade
because of the vast amount of money now
to be made in cotton
there was increased demand for slaves to
work the plantations of the americas
and the number of slaves forcibly
brought from africa to the americas each
year more than doubled after the
spinning jenny's debut
once the first steam ships made their
made in ocean voyages in 1819
the pace of transoceanic travel also
quickened
with travel faster and safer than it had
been in the age of sale power
steem power enabled international trade
to multiply
initially the supply of potential
workers exceeded factory owners needs
this created a potentially exploitative
situation
employers didn't have any reason to pay
what might be construed as living wages
the situation was exacerbated by the
fact that many factory jobs required
little to no skill
and unskilled workers stood near the
bottom of the labor hierarchy
so
most early industrial workers labored
long hours for low pay under arduous
circumstances
men women and children
worked under conditions that compromised
their health and safety
families often work together children
alongside their parents
as they had on the farms in prior
generations
and indeed
child labor was a necessity for most
poor families
the oxford historian jane humphries
places the number of child workers in
early 19th century britain at more than
a million
of these 350 000 were between the ages
of 7 and 10.
they constituted 15
of the british industrial workforce
were so many children employed
it wasn't just that they came to work
with their parents each day
factory owners viewed them as useful and
cheap
children performed jobs suited to their
small stature
they would stand at spinning machines
and repair breaks in the thread or crawl
underneath machinery to clean out
obstructions
still
many british people came to believe that
employing children in dangerous drudgery
was both exploitative and distasteful
the industrial revolution and rapid
urbanization
also led to a physical separation of the
various social classes in london and
elsewhere that hadn't previously existed
the middle and upper classes
increasingly avoided poorer areas of the
city
seeing them as enveloped in prostitution
drunkenness and crime
factory owners and parliamentarians
viewed these social ills as indicative
of the poor's inherently corrupt nature
and not as signs of being underpaid nor
owing to a lack of public services and
protections
crowded cities also meant poor
ventilation growing piles of rubbish and
waste and contaminated water that
brought typhoid and diarrhea
dark damp overcrowded apartments
facilitated the spread of such airborne
illnesses as influenza pneumonia and
tuberculosis
hundreds of poor neighbors would queue
up before a single outdoor water tap for
drinking water
bass and cleaning
the water would be turned on only a few
hours a week
and you might wait hours to fill your
buckets
private toilets didn't exist in poorer
sections of town
this led to filthy conditions a loss of
dignity
and the spread of disease among tenement
residents
in 1849 the investigative journalist
henry mayhew visited a neighborhood in
southeast london known as burmanzee
where thousands of residents died of
cholera that year in this part of town
the poor relied upon drinking water
contaminated by human waste and rotting
animal carcasses
mayhew described the area as
a foul stagnant ditch
charles dickens
captured such blight in his serialized
novel oliver twist
describing the slums of south london
dickens wrote of rooms
so small
so filthy
so confined
that the air would seem too tainted
even for the dirt and squalor which they
shelter
but the most influential critique of
industrial society came from the german
philosophers karl marx and friedrich
engels
engels had worked in a textile factory
in manchester and eviscerated the
conditions he found there in his 1844
book the condition of the working class
in england
four years later he and marx published
the communist manifesto in which they
offered a comprehensive theory of human
history in which the main driver of
change was class conflict
because the gap between rich and poor
would continue growing exponentially in
this capitalist environment they
predicted a revolution was inevitable it
would overthrow capitalism and replace
it with a communist system that would
more equitably share the fruits of
production
one day after the communist manifesto
appeared in 1848 demonstrations and
riots broke out in paris and two days
later the french king abdicated revolts
also erupted in the italian states the
habsburg empire in switzerland spain
denmark and britain and even the pope
was forced to flee were marx and engel's
predictions coming true
these revolutions of 1848 were driven by
poverty and the appalling conditions
created by industrialization but the
military power of the state was too
strong and monarchical authority was
restored
in the developing world the industrial
nations treated their colonies as
sources of cheap raw materials and
producers of cash crops they destroyed
landscapes forests entire ecosystems in
their extraction of gold silver and
diamonds and in their efforts to
increase harvests of coffee tea sugar
and rubber
european scientists were aware of the
devastating consequences of this british
east india company scientists reported
in 1852 on the probable global impacts
of the destruction of tropical forests
even mentioning potential climate change
animals also faced worldwide devastation
the furbearing mammals of the russian
steps and the american prairies were
pretty well exterminated by 1914 as were
huge numbers of birds and their habitats
some of this activity was purely
recreational but devastating nonetheless
in africa british hunters shot thousands
of antelope elephants giraffe and
rhinoceros in africa they shot tigers
from high on elephants until by the
early 20th century few tigers remained
in 1900 the british government hosted
the first international conference on
african wildlife which achieved little
but established precedence for more
productive efforts in the 20th century
all these effects were a product of the
industrial revolution which began on a a
rainy little island with a coupling of
coal burning steam engines to textile
manufacturing
the age of modernity had begun who could
have foreseen the incredible impact it
would have on human lives and on the
environment that sustained our species
[Music]
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
on one dream and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel for
new episodes of perspectives and you can
watch previous ones here